buenas noches la votación mejor dicho el
debate se inició a las 4 de la tarde
quizás no termine esta noche y la
votación se realice el día lunes lo que
podemos ver es que hasta el momento han
hablado 40 legisladores y solamente se
ha manifestado que las bancadas del
frepam y unión por el perú se inclinan
por la vacancia presidencial por lo que
se está viendo no van a alcanzar los 87
votos y tal como están las cosas se va a
requerir quizás de un nuevo audio o
vídeo que termine inclinar la balanza
por la votada por la destitución del
presidente martín vizcarra
francisco pero en caso de que buscara
logre mantenerse en el cargo cuál sería
su futuro político y también el del país
el presidente de martín vizcarra el
escribidor que es inocente de los cargos
pero va a tener que trabajar muy fuerte
para recuperar la confianza de los
peruanos y al mismo tiempo de sus
enemigos políticos desde el parlamento
martín vizcarra se encuentra en un
momento político débil ella no puede
cerrar el congreso porque se encuentra
en su último año de gestión y a duras
penas va a tener que resistir los
ataques del parlamento que se dicen que
van a tratar de conseguir nuevos
indicios nuevas pruebas para volver a
someter a martín vizcarra a un nuevo
juicio político
pues es la información que nos brinda
francisco zacarías corresponsal de
france 24 en lima